right now Mexico receives $60 million a
year in Economic Development funds just
for you know build some uh build some
buildings from American taxpayers
meanwhile there's a poest border fentol
coming across that border the president
of Mexico who's an out- andout socialist
and does not hates America has said oh
we don't even we don't even do that here
that's an American problem you guys get
yourselves under control insulted our
country yet we give them $60 million a
year of taxpayer dollars so I have a
bill house resolution 3190 introduced by
me Congressman Alex Mooney that says you
get no Economic Development funds Mexico
until you certify you're not s fentanyl
across the country across the that's
just you know one thing that not going
to solve the whole immigration crisis
but think of the stupidity and the
craziness of giving a country free tax
dollars that's harming Us in that way
here's a quick question yeah where does
that number come from house resolution
3190 like how does how does a resolution
get a number uh it's in order of when
you put it in so so you know the house
start at number one every year yeah
starts at one every year yeah oh wow
house resolution 1 2 3 4 five actually I
had a house resolution five does
everybody race to get number one well
the leadership controls that so the
Speaker of the House the speaker of the
house is going to decide always get
number one yeah one through 10 I think
is pretty much it's always like the
speaker of the house is cool whatever
you know well it's based on an issue
that's important to American people like
what we campaigned on house resolution
five is called the parents Bill of
Rights act all it says is what they're
teaching your kids in school parents
have a right to
know doesn't reform the whole system it
just says some school systems believe it
or not in this country want to not let
the parents know what they're being
taught in the schools mcy County
Maryland was trying to do that and if
the guy who ran for governor of Virginia
McCulla said parents should have no
saying what's going on in their in their
schools so that just says right to know
you think it'd be an easy one we did
pass that one in the house by the way
the Senate hasn't passed it so as far as
the numbers go yeah they're just once
you get past the first 10 or so it's
just when you put it in it gets randomly
assigned thousands of bills are put in
every year but I mean we have to go
through all these but I know we hav't
talked about digital currencies the
White House is actually working on a
federal digital currency program like
like a national Biden run digital
currency program which we've never
authorized that's something Congress has
to authorize they are so paranoid about
Bitcoin cryptocurrency all that because
they can't control it they can't control
the American people if they have their
own monetary monetary currencies it
totally freaks them out I mean I've not
seen the Democrats in the left as
freaked out since about anything since
cryptocurrency came along so anyway my
bill bans that because Joe Biden
shouldn't even have a pilot program
we've not authorized a pilot program we
don't want American we don't want your
federal government controlling the
currency and cryptocurrency and tracking
all your purchases gun purchases you
know heck in China they have good good
uh good boy bad boy credits you know for
what kind of a citizen you are based on
what the government tracks in your
purchases so any I just brought to some
of this stuff in case it came up what
about banning uh the Implement
implementation of social credit score
systems yeah well we we don't we haven't
gotten there yet but that's kind of
where they're going they even have one
of my bills is a merchant category code
that separate separately identifies fire
merchants or ammunition Merchants since
for other purposes so you swipe your
card when you buy some ammo you want
somebody keeping track of that that's
that's the type of stuff Biden is trying
to push right now through Department of
Treasury so we need to stop that so we
don't even get to the you know the ban
on you know passing a ban on the good
citizen credits we just don't allow them
to even keep track of that information I
mean people are being freaked out by the
by the information uh investment
companies are being asked to tell how
much of your investment goes to coal and
oil and gas just give me the information
that's all well that why they asking for
that information I mean there's a reason
they're asking for that information they
want to do something with it eventually
and that's you get to the credits or the
oppression yeah and we have to stop that
stuff and it tracks before it even gets
gets further and that's something I'm
you know I need my colleagues to to be
supportive of do you feel like people
are aware of that and and like someone
like obviously like Elizabeth Warren
she's for total control of the you know
financial markets and stuff like that I
understand that but do you feel like you
have um do you feel like you have
support from other other people aside
from the freedom CS do you feel cuz I
don't feel like the Republicans are on
the same on are all on the same team and
I don't think that there are Republicans
that actually maybe they maybe if they
do understand things like cryptocurrency
and stuff like that I don't think that
they see the danger I think that they're
I mean I a lot of it I feel like you're
dealing with Boomers that have no idea
and it doesn't make any sense to him
because I'm fairly technically Savvy and
it took me a minute to understand
exactly the ramifications of something
like like the the Bitcoin Network and
and the possibilities and stuff how do
you feel about the response you get from
other people when you talk about things
like social credit system that means
that you couldn't leave your house and
stuff that unites Republicans I'd say I
mean even some Democrats may be with us
on that but say for the four years I was
on the financial services committee I'm
on it now Jeb henling was chairman when
it came to the Democrats crying
screaming to regulate cryptocurrencies
and they were every hearing they yelling
about it we did absolutely nothing no
bills
nothing we didn't have a hearings on it
we just let the free market go and let
let if that's what people want to do let
them do it and it and it actually
thrived for a period of time yeah the
first time they got to regulate the
cryptocurrency market was on the first
Co bailout Bill one of these stupid
ridiculous big Omnibus two two trillion
and end they slipped in the first ever
regulation of cryptocurrency and now
they're coming after people and they're
trying to and all they're going to end
up doing is sending it overseas yeah
they just going do it in some other
country you you can't that's not
something you can lock down it's the way
that cryptocurrency works you can't it
just doesn't have the they don't have
the ability the desire for control and
that's what this is all about do you
have a right to make your own decision
or does government make that decision
for you even if it's a bad decision what
you eat you know what you eat what you
you know whether you have a donut what
what you buy where you go you might make
what kind of Health Care you may or may
not want whether you even want Health
Care do you have the freedom to choose
to not have healthare or does the
government make you have healthare and
there's the view among the left which is
mostly the Democrat Party these days
they can decide for you they'll make the
decision for you and that's that's true
and this is why cryptocurrency freaks
them out they lose total control people
can buy and trade on their own and the
government don't even know what's going
on do you have any this is a different
subject um do you have an opinion on or
do you have an idea are you even aware
of it but the I am have concerns about
um compan like the big tech companies
obviously they they track your data and
I don't think that can do anything about
it because everything that happens in a
computer there's a log it just
automatically happens right like maybe
they don't need to track the keystrokes
on on your particular device but
everything that happens in in a computer
there's a log like that's what happens I
get it but that means that all of that
information is saved and it's also
subpoena and so James Lindsay again has
has talked about your data should be
your own and it shouldn't be something
that the the Big Data companies are just
scraping all the data they can and then
profiting off of it I think that I don't
know how you would do it but I I have a
problem with the federal government
basically having everything you do at at
their at their fingertips all they need
to do is go and and talk to the company
to get it because because it to me it
seems like it's they're just another
branch of the military industrial
complex or or an arm of the CIA but
logged in you know in everyone's home I
think it's pretty scary that they
collect all that data it really is and
we shouldn't allow it the debate we had
in committee specifically is say you
join I know any kind of company uh email
system and or you purchase you go to any
uh department store and you start
purchasing stuff the debate is whether
they have to ask you to opt in to
collect your data or you have to ask to
opt out and I would say my strong view
is you have to choose to opt in it is a
free country if you want to be able to
collect your data tell them yeah here I
want you to go and collect my data give
it to other people that sell stuff and
send me emails and give me phone calls
you opt in but they take it for them to
take it and you then have to go find a
way to opt out right it's like having an
email bunch of email things you keep
getting you can't even find how to
unsubscribe you never subscribe in the
first place I feel like all I'm ever
doing is UN I just have like 30,000
emails just collecting and I just did
five unsubscribed yesterday to see if I
can clear it out but that's the debate
and and many Republicans unfortunately I
disagree strongly feel that you should
have to be required to opt out that
private companies should be able to
collect it unless you tell them
otherwise and so uh that that is a
debate have and you know I think we need
to win that debate the other debate is
even when the internet was created in
the 1990s when it was brand spanking new
and you say we're at the same age I'm
not sure I think I'm a little older than
you I did not have a cell phone in
college I have three I have three
children and and it's hard for people to
understand that I didn't actually have a
cell phone until I was like in my late
20s how was life I didn't have that I
didn't I you know didn't have any of
that stuff we're bringing beepers back
yeah because no one here at timcast
answers their phones good uh and so it's
just like okay okay I'm going to have to
get beepers for everybody that beep and
only I will have the number nice and if
it beeps it's me what if those were
playing all along we were just trying to
get beepers back bring beepers back yo
beepers were great weren't they remember
remember back in the Beeper days yeah we
like a blue like the transparent blue
ones the really cool ones so crazy what
was that was that was that on the Iden
Network like doctor I thought it was a
doctor only thing but you what I like to
say I say when Al Gore invented the
internet in 1990s uh we had actually
indemnified you know the Facebook's all
the internet providers from lawsuits if
they censored your data said something
about you on the internet was completely
untrue which frankly happened to me um
and there's no responsibility all
whatsoever whereas if you say that to
the newspapers like you remember the
Kobe Covington kid who didn't went to
the pro lifee March the Wasington
Catholic
kid like though yeah yeah I'm I'm a fan
um Covington Catholic that's funny
Covington Catholic K went to the pro-
lifee March and then was BAS harassed by
a by a protester in the Washington Post
uh uh falsely state that it stated that
he had harassed a gentleman y the video
came out proved def definitively that
this young man that did absolutely wrong
was was really the victim of that whole
thing he got a big settlement on the
Washington Post I don't know the number
but he would Washington Post had to pay
him millions of dollars because he sued
successfully for being smeared and lied
about you cannot do that to Facebook or
the internet you can't do it they've
been indemnified by law and I don't
usually find myself on the same side of
trial ORS here or anything like that but
I think it's a high time we take away
that that ad dentification from social
media companies to just totally lie
about you or censor you yeah I I think
it's I think the way the standard should
be they do not editorialize their rules
and then they're identified but if they
editorialize their rules you get no
protection so uh Facebook YouTube all
the like let's use YouTube as an example
because this was it was a trueth for
Twitter but now that elon's taken over
it's not as true uh section 230 was
supposed to be like we get it yeah
section 230 you're going to get a bunch
of weird crap and you can you can get
rid of that stuff right abuse pictures
crime all that stuff you will not lose
your liability protection for reasonably
moderating objectionable material right
they then went really I think hate
speech is objectionable and they
interpreted it that way the law needs to
be
clarified you cannot set editorial rules
like Twitter had a rule that if you
misgender someone you get banned it's
like absolutely you are now disqualified
from ident identification if you choose
to prop up certain accounts so this was
really interesting during the there were
hearings in in Congress over um with
Jack dorsy and I forget which rep it was
they pointed out that if you live in
this area in the DC Metro and you log
into Twitter as a you sign up as a new
user Twitter by default suggests you
follow Democrats oh jeez yeah I mean and
that's a huge problem yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live live
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net